as Sebastian AO moves back into the middle with
Seth Jarvis and table terraining up front and
here we go AO get to the puck scoot out to the
wing the Kan will get this one de slaven tries
to play it around the net he will aood takes
a look little snapshot that g makes the save
here's 1245 left here in the first period another
chance a low drive and Anderson takes care of the
cardier drive so bash AO get to it after reverses
tracks his gour was there and then he'll spring
Jarvis Jarvis in on De cord he'll flip a forehand
shot and dord will make the save dord recognized
probably that he mishandled it slightly a slaven
shot blocked in the slot and Justin Williams told
me you don't pick your nickname your nickname
picks you as Everly with a backhander right on
for Anderson and if Justin Williams says that
I have to agree with it so very true I remember
more on this in a minute there's an opportuity
up for Borman Trying To Shimmy shakeing score a
little shoulder Shake he backed off Burns and
goes Upper 90 and Seattle grabs the lead one
nothing and when you're in any process of
changing now Seattle was changing and they
did so cleanly just that's to make sure to get
that puck deep at the offensive blue line and
I mean just a super move I mean it's stopping
and starting the game is about stopping and
starting the way that York Strand stopped gain
separation and the interior Jarvis will drop
this one back for AO he'll spin settle trying to
get a shot M but he got his pocket picked by Bor
Strand and he'll pull up now he'll set a one and
will come in Shore goes through the five hole and
scores d Shore set up by Bor strand five hole
through Anderson and it's a two nothing Kraken
lead and made a play and this thereafter leads
to him flying The Zone knocking a puck out of
midair and settling it on his tape he had just
started his shift on time then flies The Zone
Puck was on edge and still is able to open up
Anders unbelievable last year in the American
Hockey League backed that up in the preseason
and has truly earned his way to the National
Hockey League now the kinges now thr out to the
front Burns comes in K's crashed the net and dord
keeps it out now that is Carolina's best chance of
the period that's a big time rebound save on fost
burns jumps from the strong side with his stick
Martin one touches it to him and fos was pretty
well taken care of but still gets a good chance
by Cartier morof heads to the bench chatfield's on
and now Shore got his first of the year snaps his
shot and high on top of his blue paint Anderson
makes the save and hangs on watch this play here
good board play from Seattle see the tag when
Carolina is dialed in defensively gr granted you
have a forward back be chopped down by Belmar Cami
keeps it in again bunning ping that around Schultz
and dord will play it and now Carolina comes up
with a steal Co Mii side of the neck ground for
Ping for NES they score oh that line did the
hard work in Carolina on the board it's two to
one Marty hes with a loose change a clutch late
third periods in overtimes last year Dent blew
a tire the court was indecisive indirected it to
him and duban went heels to the ice that allowed
you to use the back of the net and eventually NES
gets on the attacking side of the park bunting
finds it and with fight he gives Carolina life
and Carolina gets a late period goal not giving up
one like they have [Applause] recently it wasn't
exactly Apollo Creed teaching Rocky how to get
back after it against Clubber Lang but it's those
team building moments and somebody who knows how
to throw hands and Brendan Lemieux and Jack jury
seeking that advice that happened yesterday
at practice as the second period's underway
tonight's officials sandl and Brian pakar have
not had a lot to do so far they've done a nice
job you know it's trended there weren't a ton
of penalties in Tampa know it's started to get
back to primarily five on five so these are the
two officials that did that game as well the can
keep the momentum throwing his Jarvis Wings one
right on and dord makes the save even when those
High danger chances happen is Carolina will throw
this one out of the Zone Foss can't handle it now
this could be a break Everly comes in forand
and Anderson steady to lost and orlock couldn't
decide if he was going to get to that puck or
not and therefore he was caught no man's land
and Everly gathers the puck you had some good
converging back checking going on from Shane
bunny go Ki and NIS come out yeah they connected
for that Kane's goal late in the first period now
a chance out front that Rings the post he just
can't buy one Carolina gets the low forward and
both defenseman caught below the goal line but n
does everything right leans into it uses the FX
on his stick and catches the p is Everly L The Bu
to Burns who will back in this but can't clear but
ears now sent down low cardier shot answered by
Anderson and he enters the Matrix on this save on
cardier but if you can get to that home plate
first especially with the way dord seeing the
Pock you're going to have success I love how
that graphic illustrates where it's coming
from and again you want to see more in that
called it home plate area as the canes work
the puck in Jarvis wrapped around for terrain
back around for Jarvis as this line starts this
third period burn shot as he was swinging for
the fences but dord comes up with a catch now
warlock gets it AC cross chadfield shipped in
a he's got Jaris with him oh tries to go short
side dord makes the save it's a two onone heck
of a job by denying the passing line by borgan
but he's trying to make dord think that he's
going trying to go for sauce terrain he was
at the end of his shift he needs to head to the
bench and he will Seattle gets the puck in The
Game Zone sure he'll slide it and Sh out a piece
of it Larson into the cane zone drop for Everly
Everly tried to get it back but Brady Shay with
a stellar defensive play now Shay he's got his
motor going Shay to the backand across NES CR
the back they score yes Barry Co K ties it in
two Brady Shay desperately makes the play
kicks it Dorothy Wizard of all style from
his left skate up to his tape eventually
you have numbers heck of a pass and Nate
just makes an even better pass to Cami on
his offside and in one motion Cami brings
it on edge almost harpoons it into the back of
the net Seattle with the first two of this one
Carolina with the last two now Everly with
time winding down just throws one towards
Anderson's net that misses everything
and we've got bonus hockey coming up
so there are the two defenseman stall was slaven
and burns and stall wins it and he will head
directly to the bench Hearns off the boards for
slaven getting the stick in mccan 30 seconds left
here in overtime mccan gets through Anderson makes
the save and then Burns clears it out to AO he had
the old Reacher on Freddy did he wasn't sure if
he had it well he grabbed it and now NIS with
it NES sends across D'Angelo holding back across
NES wait scores he does it again game over Martin
hes